[Musique]
cher journal pourquoi ne rien dire quand
on peut parler mon père m'appelle trois
fois par jour pour me raconter des
détails d'histoire sans grand intérêt
alors ne rien dire ça prend du temps
mais pas autant que de l'écouter ouverte
et je me suis retrouvé avec la casquette
qui est parti derrière ça tu vois elle
bloque la table voilà mais si je le fais
plus lentement avant mais je crois que
c'est fait pour ça en fin de compte
c'est fait pour bloquer le cantal action
n'est pas le
alors oui tu sais pas la meilleure
interpol toi ça c'est une veste le ta
merde il est là tu sais pas la meilleure
on a fait aller dîner chez le voisin
l'autre soir là c'est parce qu'ils
voient comme le poison c'est le grand
l'avait grandement grands bras voilà
qu'à un chien gros chien masta flow
center c'est pas ma staff c'est à
croiser chaud chaud et les allergologues
ça se tient bien sûr tout le peuple à sa
cervelle et je les achetais je pensais
pas oui les allergologues et je suis
prêt à me dire que je devrais parler des
des allergies de ton frère leur truc
mais pas partout mais
c'est quoi le meilleur mâle pas compris
la meilleure date a commencé en disant
ah tiens tu sais pas la meilleure t'as
jamais fini de ce qu il écrit y perd
lentement avec un seul doigt à l'adresse
d'un gps
parce que forcément ça fait gagner du
temps d'éviter les bouchons
je la connais un dress mais aussi je la
connais mais s'il est pour les
embouteillages ça je ne connais pas les
embouteillages mais on y serait déjà oui
peut-être mais qui va sano vapiano voilà
at non attends je te montre un truc
parce que ça ça va te faire ils me
transfère des compilations de blague
qu'il malheureux montre quand je le vois
[Musique]
je vais envoyer celle là dans ses
discours il fait des détours des sorties
de route qui se perd en chemin il prend
son temps comme en art et on est à 250
mètres au-dessus de la mer voilà ah non
mais c'est important de savoir que ça si
le parking était la crise est inondée
une erreur s'est produite
envoyez les uns tout est hyper lent mais
au moins il profite du moment présent
[Musique]
sur vos pas vous la pressez pas si c'est
moi j'y vais à pied c'est un vrai papa
du jeu oui mais même à pied si les
travaux mais non on est en train de
parler là oui mais tu m'appelles monstre
à combien suite hauteur du besoin et on
voyait
on va y aller à pied aussi alors c'est
vrai je suis impatiente et je sais pas
apprécié chaque instant mais je t'en
supplie ne cesse jamais de me raconter
les mêmes détails papa
car si je n'ai pas tout mon temps celui
qui me reste il est pour toi
[Musique]